why are my eyes closing is that cuz I'm
so drowsy I'm gonna fall over and die
cuz I can't get coffee my eyes are
closing hello everybody my name is
markiplier and welcome back to one late
night as you can see I've been wandering
around so much that my eyes are drooping
closed ight I want to find the GAVI by
can you just sit outside I don't know
what that means
oh my god I was able to open the door on
the second floor office that's what's
something I was able to do and I want to
be able to like say that that means
something put all the other doors that I
checked while I was there gone then
again I didn't go back in so maybe
there's a coffee machine like that's a
red chair red chair sounds like red
cherry cherries are like coffee beans
maybe that light up machine is red
therefore there's a red machine that has
coffee red means go goddamnit please
tell me I can open that one beep okay
yes
oh very cop I don't oh it's hot seaming
and waiting for me
mmm sings broken again better call me
okay
cool hmm apparently this saves my game
dude God ah why was it so difficult is
that so difficult what am i doing anyway
I can't even see what I'm doing Oh who's
gonna be iron bread all over again but
in a horror game god oh god please tell
me I'm moving thank you I'm moving not
faster at all
did I have coffee my eyes are drooping
oh okay what soda machines can replace
my drowsiness what does that mean find a
way to fix the vending machine I don't
know
how am I supposed to know that what is
with that what
at least I'm moving relatively zippy now
so I think that means I need to go down
the basement to find something because I
think that ghosts said something about
maintenance death I'm chill ah okay so I
need to find a way to fix the vending
machine because apparently that's my job
in this endeavor cuz I got no other job
I did my one fax what other work do I
need to do oh all right whatever so I'm
just gonna bear with it I'm gonna put
all my transgressions aside and I'm
gonna remember that I'm here to have fun
that's the bottom line I'm here to have
fun
cuz fun is what video games are and
video games are life video games are the
only thing you need a life you don't
need anything else
don't need a pic at all and get by with
everything it's long yabba-doo you this
is a trash room why am I in the trash
room I don't even know did I just blink
or did something move in front of my
face
I don't know I'm ready for the scares
now so ready I'm so eager I'm so in it
to win it
go find a way to fix the vending machine
for some reason and then I'm gonna be
I'll just smash the front of it wide
open why don't I okay so there's got to
be something down here
that's maintenance II that I could use
to fix it and somewhere another okay wow
it is dark in here
was that oh it's a sink okay that's some
sort of bathroom so over here there
might be something here lights gonna
magically pop on like that cuz the way
this thing loads objects is kind of
strange it's gotta be like a screwdriver
or something when I was playing the
escape it's out of kill for a
screwdriver and I tried
beat him up other prisoners
I couldn't get one hopefully this one's
gonna be a little more forgiving
anything anything anything at all come
on oh god it's gonna be another wild
goose chase I'm gonna be running in
goddamn circles again I don't know what
you want from me game can I get a clue
can I get a clue can I go hello please
hello
this door doesn't even work that goes to
the outside but I'm not gonna be able to
go there oh just a little anybody a to
be the area speediest of a clue ah man
I'm really sorry guys I'm trying I'm
trying to feel like I'm failing you I'm
just a big failure on the big dumb I
don't get it a 2+2 Eagles chicken ah
okay I'm gonna get this I swear I'm
gonna figure this [ __ ] out and let's see
like I'm thinking to out what goddammit
I was a DA that's nothing oh man
everything's so dark
okay it must not be down here that must
not be correct I was I didn't hear what
that ghost guy said he had the clue that
was the clue and I didn't get it
What did he say oh man I'm losing my
mind
there's got to be something it's got to
be something obvious it's got to be
something two inches in front of my face
I'd be able to figure out what wasn't so
damn slow oh this is killing me oh it's
killing me
oh it's killing me guys it's gonna be it
I'm gonna be dead I'm gonna die this is
how it ends
saud ends from a the zone ends I'm just
a friggin failure ah I can't figure out
this game I wanna I really want I really
want to guys I really want to figure it
out I want to bear it out but I'm gonna
lose bye-bye'd
the lose my mind I'm not gonna be able
to do anything I'm gonna be a failure
I'm gonna have to quit YouTube
oh oh ah I feel like my eyes are getting
more and more closed in the game oh so
bad this reflects so poorly on my gaming
skills I mean maybe maybe maybe a little
bit of the game at fault here but god
damn it
[ __ ] if I didn't hear what the ghost
said uh I was in the middle of doing the
coffee thing God What did he say what oh
I call after I'm dead now I'm dead now
I'm dead now what
what happened what new game screw it
I'll start over when I'm fast I know
where to go oh I'm not gonna fast
forward no you're gonna see every raw
moment of this shroud just go go any key
I'm skipping I'm that guy but I'm gonna
absorb his body cuz I'm actually a ghost
this guy was perfectly normal before I
entered his life and ruined everything
cuz I did I ruined everything and this
guy's life he was totally fine but then
the security cameras are just gonna show
him walking around like a robot like I
need coffee need I can't do fix machine
need to find love Ivan had a full
night's sleep for days either so how
much just suck it up and get over it
there
bloody poo alright so I know what I need
to do I immediately go to the third
floor immediately enter the office I go
do this silly facts thing I go get
coffee I listen to what the guy says to
fix a vending machine I don't go out for
movies option I'm not gonna run could
screw that the running was dopey anyway
and I'm gonna beat this game or else I'm
gonna get to the point where I can
progress it no I'm not gonna skip you
want me to skip to Brad huh too bad this
is what you get to see you see it all
marl are is raw not edited not safer TV
I don't know what the hell happened it
went black I blacked out for a bit there
okay sometimes you can see the facts out
R Giger alright okay got it
nailing it let me read the memo boom
boom boom boom WTF that looks creepy
I can't wait to see that in person okay
oh but about boo boo boo boo yabba-doo
diba doodoo okay
bloop bloop bloop bloop bloop okay all
done there I fax that out so good I'm a
good facture employee i fax real good
now I'm gonna go down and get some
coffee
cuz I'm feeling drowsy it's weird right
okay all right got the description of
outside - definitely not make that
happen - we do but I'm gonna forgive
that not gonna complain even though I've
been doing nothing but complaining I am
at fault
I will readily admit I am at fault
totally okay here we go
dammit
sings broken again better call me why
did that open why do those open better
call maintenance
is that all you said why are those
opening huh you went down this hallway
though
where's with that what is that the ghost
to bleed to beard coffee break in
progress
whoa go go go glug it got really dark
but I'm not worried about that right now
because I'm drinking coffee hooray
coffee
hey my belly hooray coffee I'm a butt in
my ears up my nose I'm a but again in my
butt alpha but coffee enema all right
whoa please tell me that was my shadow
actually please tell me that wasn't my
shadow I'd rather see something else
okay so I need to call maintenance
oh it was leading me to this phone
no wasn't that would've been too obvious
all right oye all Ryan's I need to find
zonal phrase agape vagine wait some
coffee I just got some coffee
what okay I'll just pop my head up into
the ceiling for a bit
I just got coffee I just did I just did
ah I want to get to the scary part
I loved one late night it was great
that'll happen gamestate has been saved
great right right
okay oh oh that's right bloop turtles
dig I'm sure I'm terse dig Oh No
it wasn't broken okay so maybe now that
I triggered that I can get to the phone
cuz the guy was like I better call
maintenance maintenance he'll know what
to who
nope okay got it so I mean
being totally honest here well does this
lead what is this where the hell am I
now but this isn't gonna work
nope okay I need a different key card I
need a different key card for this
how many key cards could I possibly get
in this game oh another stairwell where
does this lead out huh okay I don't know
if there's gonna be something to help
fix it Oh give give to me apexis okay
apexis key card Laser room laser boom
ladies a room okay but either way I can
get to the apexes place now and then I
can use a laser to blast through that
goddamn machine let me just check if
there's anything over here
whoa a spooky thing happened all right I
can end on that note okay so thank you
all so much for watching click here
today's more videos that I've done as
always I'll see you in the next video
I'm dead serious
bye bye
by already our twine ball or steam you
wouldn't see me again
you know that I'm immune to this Texas